at least one fourth of july celebration
will have an italian flavor this year as
the venetian is all set for the holiday
we have with a chef eduardo perez the
executive chef at mateo's restaurante
italiano at the venetian resort eduardo
thank you so much for being here today
thank you for having us it's our
pleasure what a beautiful presentation
you have going on here and it smells
fantastic thank you thank you what are
you cooking we are presenting three
dishes today uh this one is a nice uh
melon salad that you know with the heat
and everything it i thought it could be
nice if you're doing a barbecue at home
you have something nice and light
and uh so it's a heirloom melon which is
a dressy with a little olive oil salt
and pepper there is a little mint leaves
in there to give it a little flavor and
garnish with strachatella
over here we're doing a
baby sepia or cuttlefish
so we
saute it but we want to keep it nice and
uh
we don't want to overcook it so it
doesn't get too chewy
and we are serving it with a little
salad of zucchini
chestos with a little champagne
vinaigrette
the presentation at your restaurant is
always so beautiful everything is just
immaculate in fact so good sometimes you
don't want to mess it up by eating it
thank you uh you know
you you eat with your eyes first the
first impression is
how the dishes look yes and uh
you know we try to keep it seasonal so
in this case the zucchini with the
squash and everything will represent uh
more of a summer right now for those who
haven't been to mateo's tell us a little
bit about it matteos uh is uh italian of
course
we
know for a lot of for the pasta we sell
a lot of pastas in mateo we make pasta
we make all the pastas in house in fact
everything that we can make in house we
make any house nice i hate to buy
anything that's a pre-done
so if i can do it in home at house we do
it in the house so
matteos is known for
of course the pastas but also we offer
uh
fish meat and you know we try to
accommodate every
customer's likes
in fact also we just started doing our
brunch
on the weekends so we offer brunch
friday saturday and sunday from 10 to uh
2 10 in the morning to 2 p.m you guys
are very popular is it recommended that
people have reservations uh at night i
would recommend to make a reservation
because you never know
what's going on and how
busy we're going to be sometimes it
might be a little hard for you to uh to
uh get a reservation right but also now
jc gets a table the second he walks in
right of course yeah nobody asks yeah
but also keep in mind that we also have
our system restaurant upstairs at saint
mark's square okay uh
bretta austeria
which is uh also very uh traditional
classic italian cuisine
and if you cannot make reservation
mateos we can always uh bring you up to
bera and we offer pizzas we offer again
our pastas and salads
so we try to accommodate uh everybody's
taste so what is this dish you just
prepared okay so this is again i was
thinking of a barbecue you know for uh
4th of july so we just have some bell
peppers with a little red onions that we
lightly saute with a little oregano a
little parsley extra virgin olive oil
and we top it with an italian sausage a
little gramolata on top just to give it
a little freshness and uh here we have
it all right now i said it looks too
good to mess with but i am going to eat
this you have to yes you have to try it
eduardo perez the restaurant is mateos
inside the venetian thank you so much
for being here thank you very much
pleasure please please
all right
thank you katie smells delicious in here
so